I went to UFC 281 dude that was so much
fun
man when I go into the UFC things man
for me I really it's like
sleigh bells ring while you're listening
children's slings
um I don't know the rest of it but it's
like I think it's about like
like a bunch of kids broke their arms or
whatever you know what song I'm talking
about when I'm in there it's like every
fighter that I see is like one of the
reindeer and like Dana White is like
Santa
and it just
everything about it just like
and then the music starts and then the
fighters come out and they're all
Warriors
you know they're all so it's like you
y'all are doing something so many of us
can't couldn't do I was sitting there
watching it was uh Dave portnoy's and
his buddy big cat
and they were I mean they was cheering
for Molly McCann's baby
and she I mean this lady had Molly
McCain's in a damn crucifix I mean I
don't know if you saw the Molly McCann's
fight
and they had her in that damn cruise I
mean this uh who did she fight
Molly mccains
and she's British she's a Sky's a
and you know I like she got that Rough
and Tumble baby you know what I'm saying
she got that girl in her
she got to look like her vagina would
arm wrestle you a little you know she's
got that her thumb wrestle at least baby
she's got that gumption she's uh
she's a warrior
you know when she fought
um
she fought and she didn't get the win
and the girl she fought Archibald who
was the lady she fought I think Aaron
Archibald Aaron Blanche of Blanche field
and it was just a I mean I'd love to see
that fight again it was it was amazing
but I mean she had McCann she had her in
this in the crucifix you know she had
her damn I mean she had her in the damn
third Testament to be honest she really
had her
you know but Molly did not I mean she
was like gosh
she was like one of those door-to-door
salesmen that's just like
I mean she [ __ ] Kevin I mean knock knock
knock knock knock knock she just wit I
mean [ __ ] oh it's powerful
when you're sitting there watching women
do that and you know you couldn't even
do it
dude I'd have tapped brought a tap
man if I have to sneeze into my hand
real hard and there's no Kleenex bro
I'll tap I've tapped out of a hard
sneeze dude just because the pressure
sometimes it puts on my neck duh
you know damn you get a little bit of
light Whiplash and I'm out baby
I just lost to sinuses
um but that was great to be at the
fights it was just
I mean it just was magical
and people were bombed went out of Sonya
lost
but also you know it's all like the you
know it's just the story of how things
go
um
and then Poirier and Chandler you know I
I like both of these they're both
they're both totally different guys
um but both just great guys I don't
think anybody wanted to see them fight
each other except them
um but that was in an unbelievable fight
in the first round I was like who's
everybody like
I felt like we all everybody won
everybody it just like was
them thing everybody was uncut it was
just
I felt like people were I felt like
there was a minute where they were both
unconscious but also fighting
so just just wow man and then the ring
girls man we're there dang every time
they come around the ring I'm like all
right
uh yes I do
I do
dearly beloved that's all I hear every
time they go walking by we are gathered
here I do yes
oh I would be honored that's what I just
that's how I feel when they go by
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one